[Musique]
donc on a prévu d'organiser cette
intervention en deux phases alors
j'espère qu'on arrivera à regarder un
peu de temps pour les questions de la
salle mais on va commencer en fait avec
une série de questions qui ont été
préparées soigneusement par les
militants les plus investis dans la RSE
au sein du syndicat et qu'on a prévu en
forme d'entonnoir pour aborder d'abord
des notions généralistes et se
rapprocher ensuite le plus près possible
de
l'action que nous pouvons mener en tant
que représentant des personnels donc on
va commencer par un petit cadrage
général je vous livre les trois
questions vous les prendrez dans l'ordre
que vous voulez
qui font ça fait appel à des débats
qu'on a souvent dans la dans le débat
public pour atteindre les objectifs de
sobriété permettant de limiter le
réchauffement climatique
c'est quoi les niveaux d'action les plus
pertinents les individus les entreprises
les états voire des organisations
supranationales
parfois il y a des gens qui se renvoient
le singe
les entreprises justement est-ce que
d'après vous elle se saisissent
suffisamment de ces enjeux est-ce qu'il
faudrait une régulation plus
contraignante et dans ce cas-là de quel
type et puis pour qu'on ait tous seuls
les idées claires parce qu'on y
reviendra tout à l'heure pouvez-vous
nous rappeler ce que sont les scopes 1 2
et 3 en matière d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre quand on parle des
entreprises
je vais m'attaquer à la rédaction de la
copie
bon je vais être très scolaire donc je
parle des questions dans l'ordre
là sur la première d'abord il faut
s'entendre sur ce qu'on appelle limiter
de réchauffement climatique
pour celles et ceux qui auraient oublié
ce qui s'est passé l'été dernier il nous
aura pas échappé que en fait le climat
planétaire a déjà été modifié par les
activités humaines si on prend comme
niveau de référence ou comme base de
comparaison ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler
le climat pré-industriel et qui comme
son nom l'indique est le climat que nous
avions sur terre avant le démarrage des
activités industrielles on va dire
grosso modo il y a deux siècles
ce climat pré industriel était marqué
par un certain nombre de conditions on
avait moyen de latitude les climats
polaires les climats tropicaux etc les
saisons les endroits où c'est océaniques
des endroits où c'est continental
et depuis cette époque-là la température
moyenne de la planète s'est réchauffée
d'un peu plus d'un degrés
1,1 degré ce réchauffement il est pour
partie irréversible c'est-à-dire que ce
même si on arrêtait les émissions demain
matin une partie de ce réchauffement
serait toujours là dans 10 000 ans si on
a arrêté les émissions demain matin la
température planétaire s'arrêterait
d'augmenter sur la dans l'atmosphère la
température de l'océan continuerait
d'augmenter pendant des milliers
d'années parce que il faut du temps pour
que l'onde de chaleur se propage dans
l'eau à partir de la surface le
Groenland qui a commencé à fondre
continuera de fondre de toute façon il y
a un risque de déstabilisation partielle
même à ce niveau de réchauffement de
l'Antarctique de l'Ouest il y a déjà de
mémoire entre 5 et 10 mètres de
réchauffement de d'élévation du niveau
de l'océan qui est incluse dans ce degré
quelques de réchauffement de toute façon
qui va arriver dans les milliers
d'années qui viennent et la réponse des
écosystèmes va prendre des siècles
même si la température était stabilisée
au niveau actuel par exemple 10 à 20% de
la forêt française va mourir de toute
façon au niveau actuel de réchauffement
et de stress hydrique et ça c'est un
climat constant donc
limiter le réchauffement au sens de
faire disparaître le réchauffement qui a
déjà eu lieu c'est déjà plus possible
après on peut continuer dans la
définition de ce qu'on appelle limiter
les réchauffements et vous savez qu'il y
a on a signé ce qui s'appelle l'accord
de Paris en fait on l'a même ratifié à
la ratification c'est le processus
d'approbation parlementaire ou par
référendum qui fait qu'un traité devient
opposable endroit interne le quand des
représentants d'un gouvernement vont
signer un traité à l'étranger à ce
moment-là la population n'est pas
engagée parce qu'on lui a pas demandé
son avis et les gouvernements n'ont pas
le mandat d'accepter des traités
c'est-à-dire des choses qui s'imposent
au droit interne sans que le peuple
donne son avis donc il y a toujours un
processus de ratification une fois qu'on
a signé un traité qui est le processus
législatif par lequel ce qui est contenu
dans le traité devient vraiment accepté
par le pays qui s'engage conséquemment à
modifier éventuellement les dispositions
législatives qu'il avait avant c'est par
exemple le cas de tout ce qui vient de
l'Europe l'Europe ça procède d'un traité
et c'est pour ça que le droit européen
est supérieur au droit français c'est
parce que on a décidé que ça a été comme
ça nous les français
donc dans l'accord de Paris qui est un
traité nous avons accepté de faire ce
qu'on pouvait comme effort pour limiter
globalement le réchauffement à moins de
2 degrés et si possible 1,5
alors limiter le réchauffement à 2
degrés et si possible 1,5 ça suppose que
on ne met pas plus d'une certaine
quantité de CO2 dans l'atmosphère parce
qu'il se trouve que le CO2 est un oxyde
CO2 dioxyde de carbone à cette oxyde
c'est une molécule qui est inerte une
fois dans l'air donc elle a pas de
processus spontané d'épuration la seule
manière de retirer un surplus de CO2 de
l'atmosphère c'est d'attendre soit qu'il
soit dissout dans l'océan c'est un
processus de vaste communiquant soit
qu'il soit repris par les écosystèmes à
supposer que les écosystèmes veuille mal
reprendre et qui se porte suffisamment
bien pour ça
ce qui veut dire que le réchauffement
que nous aurons en 2100 ne dépend au
premier ordre que de la quantité totale
de CO2 qu'on mettra dans l'atmosphère
d'ici 2100 d'accord ça ne dépend que de
ça
il suffit de dire combien on en mettra
au total et on a le réchauffement pour
limiter le réchauffement à 2 degrés il
faudrait que les émissions planétaires
commencent à baisser de 5% par an tous
les ans à partir de maintenant 5% c'est
ce qu'on a eu en 2020 à l'année du covid
c'est ce qu'on a eu en 1945 l'année de
l'éradication de l'appareil industriel
de l'Allemagne et du Japon voilà deux
années ou sur Terre les émissions ont
baissé de 5% faudrait que ça baisse de
5% tous les ans
à partir de maintenant pour qu'on tienne
les deux degrés ce que j'ai coutume de
dire et les explications intermédiaires
figurent dans l'excellent ouvrage jaune
quand vous a conseillé
que ça signifie en gros vous allez moins
rigoler organiser une récession annuelle
de l'ordre de 3 à 4% par an dans le
monde
et votre bulletin de salaire est le lien
avec c'est ça que ça veut dire
donc ça veut dire que si les syndicats
deviennent écolo ils vont pas devoir
militer pour des augmentations annuelles
de salaire mais pour des baisses
annuelles de salaire
alors vous rigolez mais c'est ce qui va
finir par nous arriver de toute façon à
partir du moment où les ressources on
s'épuiser puisque notre pouvoir d'achat
c'est la production physique
de notre monde de machines le vote le
mien celui de tout le monde
donc il faudrait baisser les émissions
de 5% par an et pour 1,5 degrés il faut
plutôt les baisser de 8 à 9 % par an
donc organisé un peu plus qu'une crise
de leimann Brothers tous les ans dans le
monde était bon donc voilà ce que ça
veut dire limiter le réchauffement pour
que on soit bien d'accord si on est en
scénario ligne de pente ce qu'un de mes
amis a appelé non pas le business à
usuel mais le business une usual
le scénario ligne de pente est un
scénario dans lequel les émissions ne
seront limitées que par des faits
extérieurs à notre volonté alors c'est
quoi l'effet extérieur à notre volonté
il y a plus assez fort et à couper donc
il y a plus de déforestation parce
qu'elles sont toutes parties et il y a
plus assez de pétrole de gaz et de
charbon à brûler tout simplement parce
que les gisements s'épuisent
en ce qui concerne le pétrole ça a déjà
commencé puisque le pic de la production
du pétrole conventionnel c'est-à-dire
tout ce qui n'est pas le chez l'oeil
américain et les sables bitumineux
Canadiens est passé par un maximum
historique dans le monde en 2008 c'est
une information qui est passée
totalement sous l'écran radar de la
presse et si on rajoute le chez l'oeil
et les sables bitumineux l'analyse du
chiffre project c'est que très
vraisemblablement c'était 2018
il y a une actualité récente du reste
l'OPE a décidé de baisser ses quotas de
production de 2 millions de barils de
jour ils ont annoncé ça il y a deux
jours alors même que ils arrivaient pas
à produire au niveau des quotas
existants et un certain nombre de gens
dont votre serviteur se demande si ça ne
masque pas tout simplement une
impossibilité physique de produire donc
quoi que ce soit le prix du marché et
quoi que ce soit la demande effective en
fait on masque derrière un comportement
apparemment volontaire le fait que en
pratique enfin c'est pas l'OPE c'est
l'OPE plus avec la Russie en fait la
production suivra pas en particulier en
Russie qui devait passer son pic en 2021
avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine et qui
avec l'invasion de l'Ukraine la passer
en 2019 et surtout la baisse va être
beaucoup plus marquée parce qu'une
partie des gisements russes sont
exploités avec l'aide de compagnie
occidentale qui ont foutu le camp
et ça ça va induire une baisse non
rattrapable de la production dans la
décennie à venir et il y a quelques
millions de barils de jours dans cette
histoire donc la baisse de l'OPE plus de
2 millions de barils jours peut tout
simplement refléter ça fait que la
Russie peut plus donc pour en venir à ce
que je disais il y a une voiture balai
donc la baisse de la production de
pétrole la baisse de la production de
gaz le pic de production mondiale du gaz
sous-sol contrainte géologique est
attendu pour 2030 dans la mer du Nord
c'est passé en 2005 et enfin le charbon
là c'est beaucoup plus spéculatif mais
enfin ça finira par arriver un jour
aussi donc si on suit simplement les
pics de production des combustibles
fossiles en disant on fait pas d'efforts
on attend que ce soit la limitation de
la géologie qui nous y oblige à ce
moment mon analyse c'est que nous aurons
un réchauffement de l'ordre de 3 degrés
3 degrés quelque chose on n'aura pas 5
degrés parce que on y arrivera pas le
l'économie pourra pas augmenter ses
émissions jusqu'en 2100 tout simplement
parce que il y aura pas de quoi
ce qui Dieu donne manière de dire que
l'effondrement économique en trajectoire
business inusual et certains avant 2100
ce qui était très exactement les
conclusions de l'équipe médoz qu'on a
coutume d'appeler le rapport du Club de
Rome qui avait fait de la dynamique des
systèmes au mighty donc c'était pas des
écolo bithmiques descendus de leur arbre
c'était des scientifiques qui
manipulaient un modèle la dynamique des
systèmes et qui ont été initialement
issus du monde de l'entreprise
Forrester qui avait lancé cette équipe
c'était quelqu'un qui venait du monde de
l'entreprise et donc cette équipe de
dynamique des systèmes a dit tant qu'on
poursuit la croissance physique et bien
le système dans un monde physique
s'effondre sur lui-même quelque part
dans le courant du 21e siècle voilà
s'effondrer sur lui-même ça veut dire
que population production industrielle
et production agricole baisse de façon
inexorable non non pilotée et revenu par
tête quelques et ça démarre quelque part
dans le courant du 21e siècle et puis
après pour ça s'effondre
donc la question de la du scénario
contrefactuelle c'est pas un scénario
dans lequel l'économie va de mieux en
mieux jusqu'en 2100 avec des émissions
qui augmentent c'est un scénario dans
lequel c'est le bazar pour ma fin de vie
voir
une bonne partie de ma fin de vie plus
l'essentiel de la vie de mes enfants
c'est un voilà c'est un scénario dans
lequel c'est le bazar pour ces gens-là
c'est pas un scénario dans lequel tout
va bien et puis en 2100 on aura toujours
le temps de se gratter la tête pour
savoir si on se met si on passe à
l'action
voilà donc limiter le réchauffement vous
avez une petite idée de ce que ça
signifie maintenant ça signifie
j'écoutume de le dire de cette façon ça
signifie à entrer en économie de guerre
c'est pas si on veut être au bon niveau
alors une fois que j'ai expliqué ce que
c'est que limite mais réchauffements
est-ce que qui doit agir en économie de
guerre tout le monde c'est-à-dire que il
faut que l'État soit très ferme on n'en
prend pas le chemin il faut que les
entreprises soient très alignées sur les
plans globaux et il faut que les
individus participent de façon
extrêmement active en acceptant
délibérément une forme de restriction de
leur liberté par exemple on prendra pas
l'avion pour aller pour partir en
weekend par exemple on s'achètera plus
de bagnole de 2 tonnes ni même d'une
tonne et demi etc d'accord c'est c'est
quelque chose électrique ou pas duré
c'est pas le sujet donc voilà voilà en
gros ce que ça signifie ça signifie que
chacun va devoir faire sa part
et il est bien évident que tant que nous
serons en démocratie j'espère qu'on y
restera un certain temps même si le
système n'est pas parfait et bien le
consensus il doit naître dans la
population c'est-à-dire qu'il doit
naître dans la population un sentiment
d'urgence suffisant et une envie
d'action suffisante pour que on accepte
collectivement les efforts qui iront
avec ce plan au motif que ce plan nous
amènera aussi de l'espoir et de la
sécurité parce que nous piloterons notre
destin au lieu d'attendre que ce soit
des catastrophes des marges d'escalier
qui les unes derrière les autres se
chargent de mettre le système à bas
voilà voilà le la réponse est la
première question les organisations
supranationales là dedans peuvent jouer
un rôle en particulier les organisations
supranationales d'entreprises les
organisations supranationales de pays
c'est très compliqué si vous connaissez
un peu le fonctionnement des Nations
Unies je peux vous résumer la chose en
vous disant que les Nations Unies font
un truc significatif le jour où tous les
États ont résolu le problème
c'est Nations Unies c'est un système
remontant par consensus donc quelque
chose que j'ai un peu coutume de dire
c'est imaginons que tous les gens dans
cette salle vous soyez dans la même
copropriété
imaginons que vous rentriez en assemblée
donc vous êtes là à 9 heures du matin et
vous devez décider sans ordre du jour
sans chef sans syndic
et à l'unanimité et bien à l'unanimité
d'un programme de travaux pour la
rénovation de votre copropriété qui va
vous coûter la moitié de sa valeur
dans un système dans lequel chacun paye
à proportion de ses surfaces mais chaque
personne a une voix pour la décision
donc vous ayez un placard à balai au fin
fond de la cave où le pentaous du
dernier étage vous avez une voix par
contre vous avez pas la même
contribution aux charges et l'ordre du
jour est déterminé avec chaque personne
dans la salle ici qui fait une
suggestion une propose qui propose ce
qu'elle souhaite pour les travaux
d'accord et en 24 heures vous devez
arriver à l'unanimité alors qui dans la
salle pense que vous allez y arriver
voilà là je viens de vous décrire ce que
c'est qu'une négociation des Nations
Unies
en fait c'est pas une négo
c'est entériner les choses telles
qu'elles sont d'accord faut rien
attendre des coques il ne se passera
rien au Coop jamais à cause du mode de
fonctionnement des Nations Unies donc ça
permet d'en parler mais ce qui se passe
dans une coop c'est la vie que la presse
en a et rien de plus c'est voilà
donc les organisations supranationales
pertinentes c'est les organisations
d'entreprises et c'est éventuellement
les filières professionnelles qui ont
intérêt au crime donc je sais pas
l'Union des chemins de fer l'Union des
Fabricants de bicyclettes enfin des
trucs comme ça même l'Union
internationale des télécoms et pas du
tout pas du tout du tout du bon côté de
la barrière pour l'essentiel
c'est les catastrophes environnementales
donc le penser que le monde du numérique
est homogène face à cette contrainte et
donc il va pouvoir internationalement se
mettre d'accord sur quelque chose qui
est très aligné avec une baisse de 5 %
des émissions par an j'y crois pas une
seconde donc il y a quelques acteurs de
niche dans cette histoire qui eux
effectivement peuvent espérer à du bon
côté de la barrière la profession dans
son ensemble est beaucoup plus de doute
est-ce que les entreprises se saisissent
suffisamment de ces enjeux la réponse
est non
chez vous la personne qui doit s'en
saisir ce pré dans Christelle
et si on voulait être sérieux elle
devrait y passer un jour par semaine
que je ne pense pas qu'elle y passe
j'ai rien contre elle j'ai rien pour
elle c'est parler une fois dans notre
vie c'est juste pour dire que c'est
l'ordre de grandeur du temps qu'il faut
y passer et c'est le niveau hiérarchique
qui doit être concerné voilà je connais
effectivement depuis très longtemps
Philippe isolineau c'est une très bonne
relation avec lui mais la personne qui
doit infiner décider d'appuyer très
fortement sur l'accélérateur c'est pas à
ce niveau là que ça se joue c'est au
niveau du au niveau du COMEX si je
prends l'exemple de ce qui se passe à
carbone 4 les entreprises qu'on voit
essayer de faire des efforts vraiment
sérieux sur la question en général le
patron il passe du temps ou la patron il
passe du temps et c'est de lui ou d'elle
que ça vient
avec quelque chose qui est vraiment
affirmé
et c'est normal
dans les premières étapes que toute
entreprise fait si elle est sérieuse sur
la question il y a ma petite Maroc qui
est 20h de formation et le fait d'avoir
un système de comptabilité physique
adapté au problème puisque l'information
sur la manière de gérer la baisse des
émissions n'est pas contenue dans les
prix
or chez Orange vous avez un truc qui
s'appelle un compte de résultat
et je sais pas combien il y a de
comptables et de contrôleurs de gestion
chez vous si je fais le total de
l'interne plus des bigfort plus de
l'externe plus de tous les consultants
etc mais enfin je pense que ça totalise
bien quelques milliers de personnes
et je pense que ça quand ça vous y
consacrer bien quelques pourcents de vos
dépenses iTunes si vous voulez être
sérieux sur le carbone faut faire pareil
donc si on veut être sérieux sur le
carbone il faut qu'il y ait un système
de comptabilité carbone interne qui
désagrège les opérations jusqu'au
décisions unitaires ça veut dire que
chacun d'entre vous dans cette salle là
quel que soit votre niveau de
responsabilité quel que soit votre
fonction à chaque fois vous avez une
décision à prendre vous pouvez mettre en
balance l'aspect économique et l'aspect
carbone
voilà il faut que la comptabilité
carbone soit suffisamment désagrégée
pour vous permettre de faire ça ça vous
coûtera quelques pourcents de vos
dépenses IT si vous faites ça et ça vous
demandera quelques centaines de
personnes à minima en interne qui pilote
le système voilà tant qu'on en est pas
là c'est qu'on n'est pas vraiment
sérieux sur la question
la deuxième chose qui on peut faire des
trucs mais on n'est pas holistique
la deuxième chose c'est que on ne sait
pas gérer un problème qu'on n'est pas
capable de décrire
et donc c'est mes fameuses vainqueurs de
formation dont je pense que c'est le
talon bas c'est pas la bande supérieure
c'est le talon bas de du temps qu'il
faut passer pour entrer dans la
compréhension du problème c'est à dire
bien en comprendre les côtés physiques
bien en comprendre les liens avec
d'autres problèmes environnementaux
qu'on a la question de l'espace la
question des métaux la question de la
biodiversité etc parce qu'il y a des tas
d'effets de bord et c'est très vite fait
de faire des conneries au nom du climat
dans d'autres domaines
il faut avoir la notion des échelles de
temps et des ordres de grandeur pas plus
tard que ce matin j'ai fait un petit
post LinkedIn pour me moquer de deux
articles de presse qui parlent d'aller
faire pousser des courgettes sur la lune
et qui oui oui France Info va faire ça
et pas très il y a pas très longtemps la
sûreté F1 il y avait un sujet au JT sur
envoyer une station solaire en orbite et
il y a également des gens qui pensent
qu'on va miner les astéroïdes ça veut
dire aller chercher des minerais sur les
astéroïdes bon quand vous faites des
calculs d'ordre de grandeur vous rendez
que tout ça est complètement délire vous
rendez compte que tout ça est
complètement délirant juste pour les le
minage des astéroïdes le programme
Apollo en dollars actuel c'est un polo
qui consistait à aller sur la Lune en
dollars actuel a coûté 250 milliards de
dollars il a permis de ramener 400 kg de
roches de la lune
alors je sais bien qu'avec des vaisseaux
automatisés etc on fera mieux mais pas
de problème mais quand même ça vous met
de la tonne de minerai à 500 milliards
de dollars sachant que la tonne de
minerai de fer c'est 300 dollars bon
donc moi je veux bien alors toute
l'information physique n'est pas dans
les coûts ok mais enfin si je faisais un
calcul de rendement énergétique ou de
rendement physique je tomberai sur des
ordres de grandeur qui sont pas très
loin donc je pense que on découvrirait
que la dépense énergétique est un
million de fois supérieur au bénéfice
énergétique qu'on va en retirer donc le
donc vous oubliez ce genre de trucs et
faire pousser les légumes sur la Lune
avant qu'on fasse pousser les deux
milliards de tonnes de céréales afin de
culture végétale principale que nous
avons sur terre sur la Lune il va se
passer du temps voilà donc il faut
absolument sa culture et aux ordres de
grandeur mettre de côté les fausses
bonnes solutions parce qu'on aura on n'a
pas deux essais dans cette histoire on a
déjà gaspillé une partie du premier
essai on n'aura pas deux essais
donc voilà les deux incontournables pour
qu'une entreprise s'attaque sérieusement
à la question c'est avoir un système de
pilotage physique en interne
et avoir des gens qui sont formés de
telle sorte qu'ils soient capables de
comprendre
où sont les décisions compatibles avec
la solution au problème et où sont
celles qui ne le sont pas même si c'est
celle-là qui vont prendre
est-ce qu'il faudra une régulation plus
contraignante oui parce que c'est
évident que à un moment on peut pas
compter que sur la bonne volonté des
gens et le consultant que je suis depuis
20 ans et le petit chef d'entreprise que
je suis aussi pour vous dire que une
entreprise ni neuve que sous la
contrainte donc pour qu'une entreprise
Innov il faut les taper sur la tête la
mienne la vôtre voilà et la bonne
question c'est quel est le niveau de
Nyon qu'on doit vous donner pour que
vous aviez à la bonne vitesse mais
l'idée que il va se passer des choses à
la bonne vitesse sans contrainte c'est
totalement faux
par contre comme nous sommes en
démocratie il faut que la contrainte
soit à minima comprise et acceptée il
faut qu'elle semble légitime et logique
compte tenu du problème que nous avons à
traiter alors un exemple que j'aime bien
prendre et celui du tabac il y a 20 ans
il y a 30 ans on aurait fait cette
réunion la moitié des gens enfin la
moitié peut-être pas mais enfin une
bonne partie des gens et fumer dans la
salle
aujourd'hui il viendrait pas à l'idée
même des fumeurs qu'il y a dans la salle
qui je conseille d'arrêter mais ça le
sujet
d'en griller une d'accord
ça vous viendrait pas du tout à l'idée
donc même les fumeurs acceptent très
facilement une contrainte qui est que on
fume pas dans cette salle
il l'accepte parce qu'il la comprennent
ils comprennent que c'est pas bon pour
leur santé que c'est pas surtout pas bon
pour la santé de leurs voisins qu'il
aura rien demandé et donc ils acceptent
cette contrainte globale il faut en
arriver exactement au même niveau avec
les caisses la question des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut arriver au niveau dans laquelle on
considère que la contrainte qu'on nous
impose est légitime donc il faut que la
population accepte que on limite la
vitesse à 110 sur autoroute que on
interdise aux gens de garder une
chaudière à fioul ou à gaz etc il faut
accepter ce genre de choses et que on
accepte l'idée que on va capter les
débits sur les abonnements data
et que on n'est pas un truc illimité et
que si les gens veulent la 5G plutôt que
la 4G ben ils paieront de cinq fois plus
cher
parce que sinon on attendra de
télécharger le film un peu plus
longtemps et dans Netflix et dans le
métro on fera des Sudoku le regarder
Netflix et voilà donc c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est c'est ça que ça va
servir là en ce moment il y a Facebook
qui est en train de nous vendre le
métaver avec des chirurgiens qui
répètent une opération c'est les
foutaises ça va essentiellement servir
exactement comme la vidéo à faire du
divertissement du jeu du porno et les
dents du petit dernier qui fait à eux en
3D quoi
donc c'est essentiellement à ça que ça
va servir donc
des casques de réalité virtuelle voilà
ça va servir à ça donc la
l'idée qu'il faut accepter la
restriction et quelque chose qui ne peut
pas aller sans une éducation sans une
compréhension du problème et sans un
effort collectif parce que c'est évident
qu'on n'accepte pas une restriction
quand on est le seul à la voir donc il y
a une notion également très importante
dans cette histoire qui est la qui est
la collectivité
les régulations qui ont ma faveur
maintenant c'est essentiellement les
régulations réglementaires il y a j'ai
très longtemps enfin j'ai longtemps il y
a longtemps plus exactement il était
très favorable à la taxe carbone
aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que ça
puisse être l'outil principal d'une
politique parce que c'est trop lent si
vous voulez de la taxe soit socialement
acceptable il faut pas qu'elle soit très
élevée au départ il faut qu'elle monte
doucement mais il faut ça veut dire que
il faut de la visibilité sur la vitesse
à laquelle ça monte et la visibilité
avec les pouvoirs qui changent toutes
les quelques années c'est compliqué et
par ailleurs il aurait fallu s'y prendre
il y a 20 ans pour mettre en place une
taxe qui monte doucement là maintenant
c'est un peu compliqué et puis il y a
une il y a une défiance du monde
politique qui fait que plus d'argent
pour la puissance publique qui nous
gouverne si mal c'est quelque chose que
les gens ont du mal à accepter ça veut
pas dire que la taxe soit un mauvais
outil mais ça veut dire que sa mise en
oeuvre en pratique est souvent
compliquée la réglementation est
beaucoup mieux acceptée en fait si on
dit aux gens sera interdit de remplacer
sa chaudière à fioul par une chaudière à
fioul et tous les gens qui gagnent
suffisamment leur vie le font à leur
frais et les autres la collectivité les
aidera c'est quelque chose qui en fait
est mieux accepté donc je suis partisan
aujourd'hui d'y aller surtout par la
réglementation
enfin dernière question celle-là il va
être plus courte et plus facile c'est
quoi les SCOP 1 2 3 c'est une expression
qui est apparue sous le l'impulsion
d'une organisation qui s'appelle le gag
protocole qui est une coalition
d'acteurs dans laquelle il y avait le
World resident
je sais plus lequel et qui a travaillé
en parallèle de votre serviteur à
l'époque où je faisais le bilan carbone
et au moment où moi j'ai mis au point la
nomenclature du bilan carbone avec une
grosse vingtaine de postes d'émissions
qui renvoyaient à des processus le
déplacement des salariés pour venir
travailler le déplacement des clients
pour venir acheter l'achat des matières
premières le l'énergie de fonctionnement
du site etc donc tout ça c'est des
processus donc le bilan carbone avait
d'entrée de jeu une nomenclature par
processus au motif que dans une
entreprise un processus il y a toujours
quelqu'un pour le gérer donc avec cette
approche c'était sûr qu'il y avait
toujours une personne à qui les
résultats allaient parler
le GH protocole
avait sorti un truc avec on a trois
scopes je sais pas pourquoi ça et donc
ils avaient ils étaient plutôt partis
sur une approche juridique donc le
scopin c'est les émissions qui sont à
vous c'est celle dont vous êtes
juridiquement responsable donc c'est les
sources d'émissions que vous détenez
juridiquement votre chaudière que vous
détenez des engins qui font de la
manutention sur site que vous détenez
le SCOP 2 c'est toujours dans votre
responsabilité juridique directe au sens
où c'est des achats d'énergie donc c'est
les émissions de l'énergie que vous
achetez mais qui n'ont pas lieu sur site
typiquement la production électrique et
le SCOT 3 c'est tout le reste
enfin qui est responsable de tout le
reste dans une entreprise qui est
responsable à la fois de la maintenance
des bâtiments des achats d'ordinateurs
de la gestion de la politique de
déplacement professionnel et
l'utilisation des produits personnes
donc ce scope 3 servait à rien
et en fait le GHG protocole a fini par
piquer la nomenclature du bilan carbone
dans le cadre d'un groupe de discussions
à l'ISO parce que le bilan carbone a
fini par servir de de colonne vertébrale
à une norme enfin qu'un cahier technique
plus exactement ISO qui a repris en gros
ça ne manque la nature et donc j'ai AG
protocole a fini par dire la manière
dont il faut compter les émissions c'est
dans les postes suivants qui sont
exactement les postes du bilan carbone
voilà
donc le SCOP 3 c'est tout ce qui n'est
pas les émissions directes ou l'énergie
achetée mais en fait ça n'a pas
d'intérêt de la plélescope 3 ce qu'il y
a de l'intérêt c'est de revenir à une
analyse par processus parce que dans les
entreprises qu'on sait gérer c'est des
processus
on a déjà un certain nombre de réponses
y compris à des questions qui vont
suivre puisque là on va commencer à
affiner l'entonnoir et de parler des
impacts environnementaux du numérique
alors d'abord une petite frustration il
n'y a pas de chapitre sur le numérique
dans le plan de transformation de
l'économie française mais pourquoi ça
ensuite les impacts environnementaux du
numérique ne se limite pas aux émissions
de CO2 vous l'avez effleuré mais on peut
y revenir un peu plus ça consomme
également des métaux des terres rares de
l'eau donc si on peut avoir quelques
points de repère c'est intéressant et
puis
vous avez parlé des organisations
professionnelles les nôtres la GSMA qui
gère les protocoles mobiles
les gens qui font la communication
officielle sur la 5G bien sûr ils disent
que la digitalisation ou la numérisation
ça permet d'éviter des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre dans d'autres secteurs
donc ça nous intéresse de savoir ce que
vous pensez de tout ça
alors il y a pas de chapitre sur le
numérique dans le plan de transformation
de l'économie française tout simplement
parce qu'on avait déjà commis plusieurs
travaux sur le sujet avant au shift
projet et donc c'est une simple question
de forme en fait dans l'esprit vous
pouvez considérer que ce qu'on a proposé
sur le numérique en fait partie aussi on
est juste pas allé au stade des
recommandations on n'était pas mature en
fait dans le sur le numérique au moment
où on a fait le PTF pour proposer des
recommandations pour aligner le
numérique avec une baisse de 5% des
émissions par an mais c'est working
progress au sens où on est en ce moment
en train d'essayer de trouver puisque
nous sommes une petite organisation
chiffre project donc on est en train
d'essayer de trouver le financement pour
faire ça donc en fait ce qu'on voudrait
faire c'est un livre blanc du numérique
pour aligner le numérique avec 5% de
baisse des émissions par an
alors il y a un lien entre la première
et la troisième question on a du mal à
trouver des gens qui nous financent
facilement tout simplement parce que
nonobstant les déclarations faites sur
le côté je vais diminuer les émissions
chez tous les autres grâce au numérique
en fait les gens savent très bien que
c'est pour partie de la façade et que si
on veut aligner l'industrie du numérique
avec une baisse de 5% de 5% pardon de
baisse des émissions dans le monde ça va
notamment contracter le numérique
alors pourquoi est-ce que ça va
contracter le numérique c'est la réponse
à la question 2
enfin 1 et 2 quand vous regardez d'où
viennent les émissions du numérique dans
le monde
qui par ailleurs font aujourd'hui de
l'ordre de 4% alors c'était 4% en 2018
quand on a sorti le rapport du chiffre
project aujourd'hui c'est peut-être 5
des émissions planétaires
tout compris là dedans vous avez en gros
la moitié qui est lié à la fabrication
et au renouvellement des composants
matériels donc l'écran connecté que j'ai
sous le nez là
les téléphones que vous avez tous dans
votre poche ou sur les jambes les
ordinateurs que vous avez les composants
de réseau donc ce qui permet de faire le
packbone d'orange etc les antennes
relais etc et bien la fabrication enfin
les émissions liées chaque année à la
fabrication de tout ça pour accroître
renouveler le parc c'est la moitié de
l'empreinte
l'autre moitié de l'empreinte c'est les
émissions de fonctionnement de tout ça
dans laquelle vous avez alors donc sur
50% des émissions vous en avez 20 qui
viennent du fonctionnement des serveurs
et 30 qui viennent du fonctionnement de
tout le reste donc les réseaux et les
terminaux donc l'électricité de cet
écran l'électricité des ordinateurs
l'électricité des smartphones etc
l'électricité du réseau
le
si on veut baisser ça de 5% par an on y
arrivera pas avec des mesures
strictement techniques au surplus dans
un monde où le trafic data doit
augmenter de quelques dizaines de pour
cent par an
ça va être à peu près ça je sais que
dans les banques c'est 30% par an je
pense que ça doit être quelques dizaines
de poursant par an d'une manière
générale
ça voudrait dire que on arrive à faire
tous les ans 35%
d'efficacité énergétique
par octet ou par centimètre carré
d'écran ou etc et je ne pense pas qu'on
y soit
donc bien évidemment si on veut baisser
les émissions du numérique de 5% par an
comme celle de tout le monde on va
devoir limiter les usages et en
particulier l'usage de la vidéo
c'est ça qu'on va devoir limiter on est
passé dans des systèmes qui sont
beaucoup plus gourmands en ressources
physiques ces dernières années et
décennies par exemple la télévision
hertzienne
numérique ou pas était beaucoup moins
gourmande en ressources que la
télévision pointe à point qui passe par
le réseau fibre
c'est évident donc aujourd'hui on est
plutôt dans le sens où on va vers une
augmentation de la consommation
d'énergie et de matière par usage plutôt
que l'inverse
pour vous donner des des ordres de
grandeur la fabrication d'un smartphone
d'un fabricant mondial que je ne
nommerai pas qui est une des premières
capitalisations boursières du monde
c'est à peu près c'est un peu moins de
100 kg de CO2
donc typiquement chez vous une
contribution à la baisse des émissions
de CO2 c'est d'arrêter de pousser les
consommateurs à renouveler leur
smartphone et c'est au contraire de les
pousser à le garder le plus longtemps
possible
idem pour les ordinateurs mais
évidemment si vous gardez vos téléphones
le plus longtemps possible ça veut dire
que ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler le
progrès technique se passe beaucoup
moins vite puisque à chaque fois vous
renouvelez votre appareil vous avez un
truc qui prend des meilleures photos qui
je sais pas quoi enregistre plus de
vidéos un meilleur débit enfin etc si
vous le gardez 10 ans au lieu de le
garder deux ans vous avez pas ça
pareil pour les ordinateurs il faut
voilà et enfin comme le fonctionnement
des serveurs c'est 20%, bah il faut
limiter le fonctionnement des serveurs
et donc il faut limiter l'inflation de
données et même la faire baisser alors
ça peut aller chercher loin par exemple
dans le domaine du grand public c'est ce
que je viens d'évoquer c'est renouveler
le moins souvent possible le matériel et
limiter les débits notamment vidéo
mais dans le domaine professionnel
l'inflation réglementaire ça conduit à
l’inflation de Data par exemple dans le
domaine bancaire l'obligation de la
comparaison des prix etc ça duplique des
flux enfin bon donc vous êtes ravi parce
que derrière Obs fait de bonnes affaires
mais c'est quelque chose qui pousse
structurellement voilà on a tendance
quand vous regardez bien ce qui se passe
dans le monde à ajuster la complexité
réglementaire du monde à la puissance
informatique
demain matin si on n'avait pas
d'ordinateur j'en avais plus
d'ordinateur du tout on serait
totalement un foutu de gérer le corpus
réglementaire que nous avons aujourd'hui
à gérer
un foutu de le gérer juste un foutu ne
serait-ce que pour commencer on pourrait
pas tenir vos comptes sur papier
alors vous êtes obligé de tenir des
comptes donc vous avez aujourd'hui le
corpus réglementaire on est incapable de
le gérer sans ordinateur c'est-à-dire
sans les 40 métaux vous avez dans un
ordinateur donc aujourd'hui les
obligations réglementaires et trafic
data ça porte un nom ça s'appelle du
cuivre de l'indium de l'arsenic du
chrome du de l'étain du plomb du fer
voilà ça porte ce nom là
le donc ce qu'on va trouver dans les
ordinateurs les terres rares c'est bon
vous en avez un peu vous avez de
l'indium du gadolinium etc l'indium dans
les écrans mais vous avez surtout des
métaux ordinaires vous avez de l'or en
fait ce qui vaut le plus cher dans un
smartphone quand on le recycle c'est
l'or les deux métaux qu'on va récupérer
dans un smartphone classique c'est l'or
et cuivre éventuellement l'étain tout le
reste par la poubelle parce que c'est
trop dilué trop mélangé et l'énergie de
récupération de chaque composant pris
individuellement et beaucoup trop élevé
donc on en fait rien on en passe ça dans
un coin où ça reste dans vos tiroirs
parce que ça peut toujours servir comme
disait Gad Elmaleh
vous avez également de la oui de l'eau
vous en utilise et du reste ça peut être
un sujet parce que les fondeurs de
semi-conducteur quand ils sont dans des
endroits dans lesquels il y a une
pénurie d'eau il y a une sécheresse ça
peut arriver ça peut les affecter de
deux manières différentes d'abord parce
que l'usine elle-même a besoin d'eau et
ensuite parce que l'usine a surtout
besoin d'électricité et si vous êtes
dans une un endroit par exemple si jewan
ou l'essentiel de la production est
hydroélectrique ben s'il y a plus assez
d'hydroélectricité on met la production
des usines au ralenti il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui on a bâti notre monde sur
la disponibilité perpétuelle de
matériaux qui ne seront pas
perpétuellement disponibles donc je vous
invite à réfléchir à qu'est-ce qui se
passe si demain matin on peut plus
réapprovisionner en plus
on a déjà eu un petit aperçu voilà et
ben ça n'est qu'un apéritif parce que
c'est évident que moins de pétrole c'est
un monde qui va se démondialiser
or les 50 métaux qu'on a dans un
ordinateur il y en a pas en France parce
qu'il y a pas de mine alors on pourrait
rouvrir certaines mines mais on les aura
jamais tous les 5 ans parce que les
composants miniers qui vont rentrer dans
les dans les ordinateurs seront de plus
en plus difficiles à extraire de la
croûte terrestre parce que la teneur en
métaux des mines baisse pour vous donner
un ordre de grandeur quand on a commencé
à exploiter le cuivre en Espagne à
ryotinto
il y avait à peu près 200 kg de cuivre
par tonnes de minerais aujourd'hui la
teneur moyenne en cuivre dans le monde
c'est 4 kg de cuivre par tonne de
minerais
donc ça veut dire que la quantité
d'énergie qu'il faut dépenser pour
extraire une tonne de métal des
entrailles de la terre n'arrête pas
d'augmenter donc il faut plus de métal
pour la transition et il faut mais il
faut plus d'énergie par tonnes de métal
donc on va avoir un petit sujet
et puis cette énergie elle est
essentiellement fossile
enfin voilà donc on a on a d'autres
limites qui vont s'appliquer au
numérique que simplement la limite en
CO2 il y a notamment une limite de
ressources et une limite d'énergie et
cette limite de ressources et cette
limite d'énergie
peuvent éventuellement nous jouer des
saltours et finiront par nous jouer des
saltours si c'est pas nous qui mettons
les limites
ah bah pardon j'ai pas répondu à la
dernière question mais je vais y aller
très rapidement j'ai vu passer une étude
qui a été commise par Orange je crois
donc je vais dire beaucoup de mal de la
maison qui vous héberge 10 ans que pour
un et mis dans le numérique on
économisait 10 ailleurs
alors je
oui c'est pas orange pardon
notre ancien PDG était le président de
la GSMA mais alors je vais dire du mal
de votre ancien PDG du coup le je vais
vous livrer une réflexion l'empreinte
carbone du numérique dans le monde c'est
4% des émissions si on était dans ce
ratio de 1 pour 10 ça veut dire que le
numérique aurait fait économiser 40% des
émissions je pense qu'on le verrait
voilà donc en fait ce calcul ne repose
sur rien je n'ai pas lu dans le détail
pour savoir où est-ce que il pêche mais
c'est évident qu'il pêche
en fait quand vous regardez c'est une
courbe que je montre souvent donc vous
pouvez aller voir ça sur n'importe quel
enregistrement vidéo de mes conférences
quand vous regardez la courbe des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde depuis un siècle et demi on ne
voit strictement aucune inflexion de
cette courbe au moment où le digital
prend son essor aucune
donc ce qui veut dire que l'effetnet du
digital savent absolument pas été de
ralentir la hausse des émissions
absolument pas
on continue à empiler en fait
alors justement on va en venir je ne
vois pas comment les jeux en ligne
Netflix et le porno pourrait faire
baisser les émissions
[Musique]
je ne reviendrai pas sur les propos du
maire de Grenoble qui avait été très
controversé mais on est un certain
nombre à se demander s'il n'est pas
fortement raison
et c'est très difficile pour nous de
bosser chez Orange et de dire qu'il faut
qu'on fasse en partie Hara-Kiri à ce qui
fait manger notre boîte c'est pas juste
rien on y reviendra à la fin mais
justement on va commencer à rentrer de
plus en plus près dans le vif du sujet
concernant orange un son sans dévoiler
d'informations confidentielles est-ce
que vous avez en tête comment si tu sur
à chacun des fameux scopes 1 2 et 3
l'entreprise a affiché un objectif de
neutralité carbone à 2040 est-ce que
c'est réaliste et qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire pour y arriver et puis justement
pour faire le lien avec ce qu'on prétend
à la GSMA ou dans la pub sur la 5G qu'on
va
diminuer à l'empreinte des autres
secteurs d'activité on pourrait se dire
que les opportunités d'affaires liées à
la réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale ça constitue un pan
important de notre activité or dans le
document d'enregistrement universel
d'Orange qui fait 600 pages il y a une
page la 312 pour les curieux qui évoque
ce sujet donc nous on se dit qu'on
pourrait sûrement aller plus loin alors
je fais juste une oui parce que j'ai pas
mis ma note de bas de page le document
d'enregistreur universel pour ceux et
celles dont c'est pas l'oreiller c'est
la Bible qu'on donne tous les ans aux
actionnaires avant la G et que nous à la
commission économique du C5 ou au
conseil de surveillance de partenariat
salarié
ont dépouilles tous les ans sachant que
nos administrateurs eux ils font encore
plus et moi je suis une axe donc je sais
c'est à dire qu'on lit tout et on valide
tout avant la G voilà donc nous les 600
pages on les connaît
alors
l'essentiel des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dont dépendent des activités
d'orange parce qu'il faut bien voir
qu'un bilan carbone c'est un lien de
dépendance c'est pas un lien de
responsabilité je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure le lien de responsabilité il ne
s'exerce que sur les sources donc vous
êtes propriétaire donc on va trouver les
chaudière à gaz de vos bureaux
essentiellement
et ça se limite à peu près à ça nos
équipements réseaux aussi alors vos
équipements réseau ils sont déjà plus
les émissions correspondantes sont déjà
plus dans les équipements réseau sauf
pour les groupes électrogènes que vous
pourriez posséder pour les sites vitaux
vous en avez quelques-uns j'imagine des
groupes des groupes électrogènes pour
les équipements vitaux voilà donc c'est
ça qu'on va trouver par contre les
émissions de la production électrique
donc les émissions de la centrale de
Saint-Avold de charbon que nous allons
remettre en service et qui alimente le
réseau ça c'est dans le SCOP 2 c'est
déjà plus dans vos épices les émissions
dont vous êtes directement dépositaire
propriétaire
donc les émissions dont vous êtes
directement propriétaire c'est une
fraction très très mineure de l'ensemble
des émissions qui permettent à
l'activité d'orange de s'exercer le
bilan carbone reflète un lien de
dépendance c'est ça qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est pas un lien de responsabilité
donc j'ai en charge le paradis vous êtes
responsable des émissions du fondateur
de puces taïwanais qui permet à vos
clients d'avoir des smartphones
je sais pas si vous en êtes responsable
ou pas responsable par contre ce dont je
suis sûr c'est que vous en dépendez
c'est à dire que s'il n'y a pas le
fondateur de puces taïwanais vous avez
pas de smartphone et donc il y a pas de
vente d'abonnement pour smartphone
voilà donc là si on regarde les
émissions dont vous dépendez
l'immense majorité se situe dans ce
qu'on appelle le SCOP 3 c'est à dire
tout ce qui est externe
à vos émissions directes et à vos achats
directs d'électricité alors cela étant
ça dépend un peu du pays il se trouve
que j'ai fait le premier bilan carbone
d'orange moi perso mais c'était il y a
longtemps donc j'ai plus tout en tête et
je l'ai pas relu en Pologne par exemple
les émissions de fonctionnement du
réseau sont extrêmement significatives
rapportées aux émissions de d'achat des
terminaux par exemple mais par contre si
on prend l'ensemble de vos activités et
notamment la France en gros ce qui va
dominer c'est le renouvellement des
terminaux
l'utilisation des terminaux la
fabrication des composants de réseau
c'est ça qui domine de très loin
derrière vous allez trouver
l'électricité que vous achetez en direct
pour faire fonctionner le réseau et les
Data Center que vous possédez si tant
que vous soyez pas passé dans le Cloud
si vous êtes passé dans le Cloud ça
passe ça passe dans ce Top 3
c'est plus chez vous c'est chez Amazon
Web Services ou je sais pas qui
ce qui veut dire que le détail de mes
communications est entre les mains de
l'administration américaine ainsi
d'avant
et
enfin il décides internet que je
consulte enfin tout ça est connu des
Américains
vous connaissez la loi extraterritoriale
des Américains des États-Unis c'est très
problématique alors je dirais que pour
faire une assiette là-dessus chez Orange
pour nos propres activités on est
essentiellement sur nos propres data
center d'accord avec de moins en moins
parce que depuis qu'on a installé teams
et orange oui orange collaboratif qui
est basé sur la solution Microsoft et
bien nous avons tous un petit cloud
personnel
Microsoft donc personne à la DSI n'a été
capable de nous dire clairement où il
était hébergé et où on est certain qu'on
dépend des lois extraterritoriales
américaines donc du moment où l'acteur
ou l'entreprise qui vous propose de
service d'hébergement est américaine ça
suffit absolument on est d'accord s'il y
a une comment dire s'il y a un ordre
d'un juge on peut y accéder
faut quand même passer par un juge mais
bon alors
le donc pour en venir à ce que je disais
donc l'essentiel des émissions dont
dépend orange sont les émissions de
fabrication du matériel de vos clients
du matériel de votre réseau du
fonctionnement du matériel de vos
clients voilà en gros c'est ça
sachant que il y a après des subtilités
méthodologiques
pas toujours très simple par exemple si
vous vendez des mobiles à des gens qui
s'en servent dans le cadre d'une
activité de transport par exemple est-ce
que vous devez mettre les émissions des
transports ou pas dans ce Top 3 parce
que bah oui s'il y a pas de transport
vous aurez plus ces clients bon donc
voilà donc il y a des tas de subtilité
méthodologiques de cette nature car 24
on passe notre vie là-dessus mais mais
en gros c'est les émissions dont vous
dépendez sont essentiellement dans ce
qu'on appelle le Scott 3
alors est-ce réalise d'afficher un
objectif de neutralité carbone à 2040
alors là je vais vous faire sauter en
l'air la réponse est non ça n'est pas
réaliste parce que en fait il ne peut
pas y avoir d'objectif de neutralité
carbone pour une entreprise prise
individuellement
la neutralité carbone c'est quoi c'est
arrivé un jour à un état dans lequel les
émissions d'origine humaine sont
compensés par le surplus de puits
d'origine humaine alors les puits et les
écosystèmes dans les écosystèmes vous
avez les écosystèmes dit naturels et
puis vous avez les écosystèmes dit
artificiels par exemple les écosystèmes
artificiels c'est l'agriculture on peut
séquestrer du carbone dans le sol en
arrêtant le labour en plantant des haies
en ayant pas le même type de rotation de
culture en augmentant les masses
racinaires etc
ça fait partie des puits imputables aux
hommes si on arrive à faire ça
je vous dis tout de suite un truc et
puis technologique là je sais pas si
vous avez vu passer là aussi cet article
sur l'aspirateur à CO2 qu'on a installé
en Islande voilà bon ça c'est du délire
complet j'ai fait un petit calcul
d'ordre de grandeur basé sur la CV de ce
truc là si on voulait reprendre chaque
année dans l'Atmosphère le CO2 qu'on y
met avec ce genre d'aspirateur à CO2 il
faudrait qu'on y affecte la totalité de
l'électricité mondiale donc il y aurait
pu un électron pour votre réseau et la
totalité du pétrole mondial donc il
aurait pu un litre de carburant pour les
camionnettes que vous utilisez pour
aller voir les antennes de réseau ce qui
est une autre manière de dire qu'on
aurait fait un système de Shadok parfait
dans lequel toute l'énergie mondiale
serait utilisée exclusivement pour des
appareils qui permettraient de reprendre
le CO2 de l'énergie mondiale bon ça
serait vachement intelligent donc vous
oubliez ce genre de truc ça ne sera
jamais à l'échelle là ça sert juste dans
un monde où il y a du quantitative
easing partout et trop de pognon à
investir à attirer quelques
investisseurs dans des trucs de gadgets
et en plus il est pas exclu que les
surface la culbute parce que le jeu du
private equity est de temps en temps un
jeu bizarre mais
ça ne sera jamais à l'échelle pour
apporter une solution significative au
problème de changement climatique donc
voilà ça fait partie de tous ces cas de
figure dans lesquels la presse vous
fournit une information sans vous
fournir un calcul d'ordre de grandeur
qui permet de remettre l'information en
perspective donc il faut le faire par
vous-même pour savoir ce qu'on vient de
vous proposer oui quand on est fainéant
il suffit de vous lire vous suit sur
Linkedin si j'ai le temps de le faire
alors donc la neutralité c'est à
l'échelle planétaire dire qu'une
entreprise serait devenue neutre toute
seule ça porte l'idée que l'entreprise
c'est toute seule avec ses seules
efforts totalement dé risqué
face à la question climatique c'est à
dire qu'elle a supprimé tout lien de
dépendance avec des émissions qui se
passe ailleurs
et qu'elle a supprimé tout risque lié à
un changement de réglementation qui
porterait sur les émissions qui se qui
ont lieu ailleurs vous êtes d'accord
avec moi je suis neutre je ne suis plus
concerné par le problème
question est-ce que vous pensez alors la
neutralité souvent s'obtient avec ce
qu'on appelle de la compensation
donc j'ai des émissions je les calcule
si possible sur le périmètre le plus
restreint possible pour que ce soit
facile à compenser et derrière j'achète
ce qu'on appelle des crédits carbone de
gens qui vont planter des forêts baisser
les émissions vendre des réchauds à gaz
pour supprimer la déforestation
qu'est-ce que je sais et donc je dis à
plus et moins c'est bon j'arrive à zéro
et donc je suis sorti du problème alors
question admettons que vous soyez arrivé
à zéro de cette manière là admettons que
les Taïwanais un jour disent alors
fondeur de semi conducteur c'est
interdit d'acheter de l'électricité au
charbon et qu'il y ait que ça à vendre
est-ce que vous pensez que le fait
d'être neutre vous des risques vous sort
du problème admettons qu'en France on
dise overnight il est interdit de se
servir d'une camionnette à pétrole pour
se déplacer alors que vous ayez que ça
pour aller maintenir les antennes ce que
vous pensez que vous êtes dé risqué vous
voyez bien que non
parce que la loi française initialement
dans le projet de loi climat là qui a
été voté il y a pas longtemps il y a
deux ans je crois disait il est interdit
de mettre neutre derrière un produit ou
service parce que maintenant vous avez
des carburants de en carbone vous avez
tout ça bon
si vous vous pouvez être neutre en
carbone total peut être aussi c'est le
même mécanisme comptable rigolez pas
c'est le même mécanisme comptable comme
disait l'autre nous vivions une époque
moderne c'est exactement le même
mécanisme comptable donc le il y a un
opérateur de centrale à charbon peut
l'être du reste Drax s'est fait attaquer
qui a la plus grosse centrale à charbon
en Bretagne s'est fait attaquer par une
ONG justement sur ce motif donc le
donc l'un neutralité d'une entreprise
n'est pas possible et la seule chose qui
est possible c'est de se mettre en
accord avec la neutralité planétaire
alors se mettre en accord avec la
neutralité planétaire ça veut dire que
on est capable d'imaginer un business
model
qui résiste à une baisse planétaire de
5% des émissions par an voilà c'est ça
s'aligner avec la neutralité planétaire
alors il se trouve que à carbone 4 on
fait ce genre d'analyse de temps en
temps qu'est-ce que ça signifie
qu'est-ce que vous vendrez toujours
autant de téléphone est-ce qu'il y aura
toujours autant de serveurs est-ce que
etc ou pas
où est l'espace de liberté qui vous
reste physiquement dans un monde dans
lequel vous cherchez à vous aligner avec
une baisse de 5% par an des émissions
c'est ça qui a un objet qui a de la
pertinence en termes d'investigation si
on veut confronter une activité enfin
c'est ce qu'on pense à carbone 4 on
l'affirme on le clame on fait des
projets en ce sens on a démarré à
carbone 4 par exemple un projet qui
s'appelle Iris qui vise à refaire pour
dire les choses très très rapidement qui
vise à faire du medose de la
microéconomie donc en gros on veut
donner aux entreprises une boîte à
outils pour se confronter à un cadre
physique restreint pour faire de la
prospective donc pas de la stratégie pas
des trucs à trois ou cinq ans mais de la
prospective donc des trucs à 20 30 ans
range des pattes dedans malheureusement
bien aimé mais si
Orange et Denis ah super bonne nouvelle
c'est récent ah alors très bonne
nouvelle merci et ben donc voilà grâce à
cette boîte à outils merci Jean-Manuel
et bien on va on va pouvoir vous aider à
savoir ce que ça veut dire même si ça
fait mal mais au moins on saura au moins
on sera
et je suis très content d'être venu ici
d'avoir appris cette nouvelle
voilà alors
le chapitre opportunité d'affaires liée
à la réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale ne fait qu'une page
est-ce qu'on peut aller plus loin
évidemment qu'on peut aller plus loin
j'en reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure aller plus loin ça veut dire
investir beaucoup de jus de cerveau sur
la question donc ça veut dire partir du
bon cahier des charges et notamment en
lien avec ce que je viens de dire c'est
l'étape d'après de ce que je viens
d'évoquer c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où vous savez ce que ça signifie
en terme d'évolution des secteurs
d'activités dans le monde dans leur
ensemble ce que ça veut dire pour les
transports ce que ça veut dire pour les
bâtiments ce que ça veut dire pour
l'industrie etc vous savez où vous
pouvez proposer des services vous orange
qui sont cohérents et après la question
que vous allez avoir c'est jusqu'au où
vous avez envie ou pas de rester
solidaire avec vos petits copains donc
dit autrement si vous vous pouvez
proposer des services et que dans le
même temps
British Telecom ou son descendant fait
faillite et Vodafone fait faillite la
question c'est est-ce que ça vous ennuie
ou est-ce que ça vous ennuie pas bon et
ce que je dis est pas complètement
anecdotique parce que vous savez très
bien que dans le secteur d'activité
aujourd'hui on aussi en permanence entre
de la concurrence et de la solidarité
et donc ça reposera nécessairement cette
question là qui est de savoir où est-ce
qu'on met la ligne de partage des eaux
voilà je sais pas s'il y a une branche
Télécom à CFE etc mais la question se
posera peut-être
de savoir si vous devez avoir une
politique homogène de défense des
intérêts chez tout le monde ou s'il y a
un moment on accepte que Bouygues face
de meilleures affaires que Free ou
Orange de meilleures affaires que
Bouygues voilà
ça va pas être nécessairement très
simple pour des organisations comme la
vôtre voilà mais mais ces questions là
vont être posées donc encore une fois
oui est-ce que c'est normal
qu'aujourd'hui il y a pas plus qu'une
page la réponse est raisonnablement oui
pour une raison assez simple c'est qu'on
sort de deux siècles de monde infini et
de croissance et donc toutes les boîtes
à outils toutes les formations tous les
ingénieurs qui sont dans cette salle
moins inclus on a été formés dans un
cadre dans lequel la question des
limites physiques et des effets
d'éviction n'était pas central dans la
manière qu'on avait d'abord des
problèmes et le fait de le fait de
passer de une page à 100 pages ça
revient à dire que on passe de de ses
effets de limite physique et d'effets
d'éviction d'un truc marginal
voire absent à quelque chose qui devient
principal
et c'est quelque chose qui demande là
aussi de la formation des gens qui vont
devoir faire ça
le fait que votre patronne va devoir
accepter qu'on fasse ça va devoir
accepter que en interne il y a des
débats forts parce que c'est évident que
ça va créer une ligne de démarcation
entre deux camps qui seront pas
nécessairement très raccords
donc ça pose la question de l'esprit
d'entreprise et de l'homogénéité à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise ça a
toujours été beaucoup plus facile dans
une entreprise de faire démarrer des
activités qui pourraient ensuite se
rajouter à ce qu'il y avait déjà que de
faire émerger des activités qui vont
remplacer ce qui existe déjà c'est pas
exactement la même chanson voilà donc
c'est pas juste la faire de mettre une
page plutôt que 10 plutôt de 50 si vous
voulez mettre 50 pages de blabla c'est
ça sera très facile la question c'est
est-ce que vous voulez mettre 50 pages
qui traduisent une réflexion préalable
extrêmement profonde et qui fera pour
partie douloureuse ou pas voilà et ça ça
renvoie à ce que je disais c'est à dire
le fait d'être capable de sautiller le
fait d'y mettre les moyens le fait de
considérer que dans la hiérarchie entre
le carbone et les euros c'est pas
nécessairement les euros qui passent en
premier tout le temps etc et donc c'est
quelque chose qui est plus proche alors
ce terme une connotation historique peu
sympathique mais ça se rapproche plus
d'une révolution culturelle que une
connotation historique peut sympathique
que simplement d'un aménagement à la
marge voilà ça ça ne pourra pas être
traité de manière satisfaisante par à la
marge malheureusement
alors justement
on va continuer à avancer dans le dur
bon je dirais que si je prends la
dernière question de la page elle tout
justement le modèle économique puisque
notre métier c'est de vendre de la
connectivité de la bande passante donc
voilà quand on vend ça en tant
qu'opérateur de télécom et Opéra et
entreprise de service numérique comment
on accompagne nos clients vers la
sobriété
et puis si je remonte dans la page bon
vous avez déjà commencé à répondre à la
question tout à l'heure mais on peut
continuer à creuser comment intégrer les
externalités environnementales dans la
comptabilité et la présentation des
résultats financiers pour que ce ne soit
pas un frein à l'action environnementale
et je remonte enfin à la première
question qui est comment convainc nos
actionnaires que l'entreprise doit
orienter sa stratégie en faveur de la
limitation de l'empreinte
d'environnementale voire en faire des
alliés pour qu'ils poussent dans ce sens
puisque alors je vais être brutal dans
mes propos mais notre direction
financière est totalement inféodée à la
vision des analystes et des actionnaires
et nous en tant que
salarié et représentant des salariés
les salariés d'orange détiennent 8% à
peu près du capital de l'entreprise et
donc on a la possibilité d'émettre des
résolutions en AG si on arrive à être
assez malin pour en émettre
quelques-unes qui peuvent
attirer l'intérêt d'autres actionnaires
que nous on peut contribuer aussi à
engager la révolution culturelle
disons-le comme ça alors les
actionnaires d'une entreprise en général
ils ont une religion qui est le résultat
parce que assez rare sont les
actionnaires qui considèrent qu'ils sont
des actionnaires citoyens y compris les
actionnaires salariés pour être un peu
désagréable et qui pense que leur
premier mandat c'est de faire en sorte
que l'entreprise limite ses émissions et
que si ça va avec une baisse continue de
la valeur de l'action c'est pas grave
voilà les gens qui pensent ça sont quand
même assez rares
alors comment convaincre les
actionnaires et ben ma réponse va
peut-être vous faire sauter en l'air je
pense qu'il faut pas chercher à les
convaincre les fois chez coin que la
puissance publique
la puissance publique un jour va vous
dire ça vous avez plus le droit de le
faire et puis la valeur de l'action on
sera ce qu'elle sera
convaincre les actionnaires j'y crois
pas enfin j'y crois assez peu alors j'y
crois dans un seul cas de figure j'y
crois quand l'actionnaire alors je vais
je vais je suis désolé je vais faire
l'apologie de l'économie de rentier du
18 du 19e siècle mais l'expérience de
carbone 4 c'est que c'est plus facile
globalement de convaincre l'actionnaire
quand l'actionnaire et le propriétaire
de l'entreprise et que de passer par des
rendements qui transitoirement se casse
la gueule c'est-à-dire de passer de 10%
de résultats à 2% de résultats si
l'entreprise n'est pas opéable si
l'entreprise elle est pas transmissible
bah si il doit faire ça pendant 10 ans
et que c'est le prix à payer pour pour
survivre et se mettre dans une
trajectoire qui est compatible il le
fera
dans une entreprise qui est côté vous
avez une dilution il n'y a pas
d'affection sociétale
les gens arbitres alors pas les
actionnaires salariés mais tous les
autres donc si vous êtes moins rentable
que Michelin ils ont acheté du Michelin
et si vous êtes moins rentable et ou
c'est les gestionnaires d'actifs c'est
nos clients aussi à carbone à 44 pardon
carbone c'est rigolo ça
le on a aussi des des clients qui sont
des gestionnaires d'actifs puisque nous
avons monté il y a maintenant quatre ans
une entreprise qui fournit de la donnée
au monde financier qui s'appelle carbone
for Fayence
et on est très très fier du reste il y a
quelques mois d'avoir une notre plus
belle prise qui est les banques
centrales de l'europeystème
client et c'est les entreprises on leur
fait c'est pardon c'est les entités du
monde financier on leur fournit de quoi
se confronter au problème c'est pareil
on n'a pas l'ambition de faire la
révolution mais on a l'ambition de les
aider à comprendre ce qu'elles font
passe leur temps à faire des arbitrages
risques rendement ils ne font que ça
donc il faut
qui peut modifier l'arbitrage de riz sur
rendement la puissance publique
donc les sols qui peuvent verdir
l'économie c'est la puissance publique
le monde financier et les actionnaires
ne peuvent pas se verdir tout seul au
détriment de leur propre intérêts
d'actionnaires ils le font pas
sauf dans le cas d'actionnaires encore
une fois propriétaire qui peuvent
accepter pendant un temps d'investir de
passer en résultat net négatifs de etc
de bouffer une partie de leur réserve
parce que ils pensent que c'est vital ou
parce qu'il pense que voilà ils peuvent
également faire ce que vient de faire
monsieur Chouinard il y a pas très
longtemps c'est-à-dire renoncer à leur
profit d'actionnaires puisque vous savez
que Patagonia les héritiers de Patagonia
ne verront pas la queue d'une et
Chouinard a transmis le capital de son
entreprise à une fondation
qui reversera la totalité des profits à
des œuvres qui luttent contre le
réchauffement climatique notamment donc
ça c'est une décision d'actionnaire qui
laisse l'intérêt strictement financier
de l'actionnaire
voilà mais pour ça alors je dis pas je
suis pas en train de dire dès que vous
avez une personne physique donc le
moindre propriétaire d'hôtel restaurant
qui actionnaire de son entreprise va
faire tout ce qui peut pour diminuer le
résultat de son entreprise au profit du
climat non j'ai pas en train de vous
dire ça par contre je vous dis que c'est
de notre observation plus facile quand
même d'avoir des gens qui s'intéressent
à la question quand ils ont un horizon
de temps très long devant eux et ça
concerne préférentiellement les sociétés
qui ont pas un gros flottant et qui ont
pas l'essentiel de leur actionnariat
détenu par des fonds d'investissement je
sais pas comment se réparti
l'actionnariat d'orange
le premier notre premier actionnaire
c'est l'État à peu près 23%
le deuxième c'est nous les salariés le
troisième c'est Blackrock d'accord et le
reste c'est du flottant
vous êtes quand même dans une situation
intermédiaire puisque vous avez quand
même un tiers du capital qui est
sécurisé
bon mais l'État n'a aucune envie de
diminuer la valeur des actions d'orange
ça c'est absolument certain
donc voilà donc donc convaincre les
actionnaires c'est compliqué et du reste
l'État est en conflit d'intérêt dans
cette histoire puisque s'il prend des
réglementations pour diminuer votre
activité au motifs que c'est pas bon
pour l'environnement et bien la personne
de la p.e se fait remonter les bretelles
voilà et Monsieur le Maire gueule
surtout que Monsieur le Maire adore les
licornes et qu'il est quand même
totalement fasciné par le numérique
donc j'espère que il va faire des pulls
rouler connectés
[Rires]
non on se moque beaucoup de lui et de
ces cols rouler en fait pour une fois il
a dit un truc intelligent c'est évident
que de s'habiller plus chaudement plutôt
que de monter le thermostat par les
temps qui courent c'est un truc
intelligent ça c'est clair disons que le
problème c'est que les choses
intelligentes qui nous disent elles
tombent tellement sous le sens que pour
un certain nombre d'entre nous on avait
déjà l'impression d'avoir compris tout
seul depuis très longtemps non c'est
surtout que c'est pas tellement relié à
une politique globale qui serait lisible
c'est voilà et donc et donc il se prend
le retour de bâton à cause de ça et ça
malheureusement c'est la loi du genre
comment intégrer les externalités
environnementales dans la comptabilité
alors il faut surtout pas les intégrer
dans la comptabilité financière c'est
justement ça qui est perturbant
j'ai un ami qui est mathématicien qui a
été un des fondateurs de l'Université
Paris Dauphine et qui est norvégien qui
s'appelle Land et qui m'avait dit un
jour un truc j'ai beaucoup la manière
dont il me l'a formulé il m'a dit on
n'ira jamais nulle part sur la question
du climat si on essaye d'en faire un
problème économique dit autrement si on
essaye d'arbitrer l'opportunité d'agir
versus l'opportunité de ne pas agir sous
l'angle économique on n'ira jamais nulle
part et il y a une raison très simple à
ça c'est que les actifs naturels sont
gratuits par convention dans l'économie
et donc préserver l'intégrité d'un actif
naturel qui par convention vaut 0
c'est-à-dire le système climatique m'a
par convention ça vaut 0 ce qui veut
dire que dans toutes les modélisations
économiques où vous avez des fonctions
de dommage
pour essayer de calculer le dommage
économique qui résulterait d'une perte
d'intégrité du système climatique en
fait quand vous regardez comment
fonctionne le modèle il est tautologique
un modèle topologique c'est un modèle
dans lequel la conclusion c'est
l'hypothèse d'entrée reformuler
différemment
donc la manière dont les fonctions donc
les fonctions dommage sont paramétrées
avec des hypothèses et donc vous
retrouvez en sortie le dommage que vous
avez paramétré en entrée avec des
hypothèses
donc le dommage c'est exactement l'envie
que vous en avez dans ces voilà donc ce
que m'a dit hier éclore un jour il m'a
dit jamais on ira nulle part en essayant
d'en faire un premier économique il faut
que ça devienne un problème éthique dit
autrement il faut que ça rentre
malheureusement dans le débat du bien et
du mal
le fait que si vous êtes très énervé par
votre voisin de gauche là qui tape sur
son smartphone et qui vous donne un coup
de coude par inadvertance vous avez pas
le droit de le coller à Ramponneau c'est
pas une affaire de prix
on vous dit pas si vous payez
suffisamment cher c'est pas un problème
économique
c'est un problème moral on dit vous avez
pas le droit point bon et si vous le
faites on vous met peut-être une amende
mais surtout on vous met en prison c'est
à dire qu'on vous colle une punition qui
est elle-même sur le plan de la morale
et de l'éthique on reprit de liberté
donc en ce qui concerne le réchauffement
climatique il faut en arriver là aussi
alors je sais pas s'il faut mettre des
gens en prison mais en tout cas ce qu'il
faut c'est que ça il faut que ça
devienne un objectif moral et éthique
parce que il y a que ces objectifs là
qui sont supérieurs aux objectifs
économiques
on accepte pour
la vie de nos enfants éventuellement de
changer de métier pour un métier moins
bien payé d'arrêter de travailler parce
qu'il faut s'occuper d'eux de cetera
donc on accepte plein de sacrifices
économiques éventuellement pour nos
enfants parce que ça relève de l'affect
parce que ça relève de la morale parce
que ça relève de l'éthique parce que ça
relève des sentiments donc tant qu'on
aura pas mis la question du changement
climatique sur ce plan là on ne pourra
pas avancer à la bonne vitesse en en
faisant un problème strictement
économique ce qui veut dire que la
comptabilité environnementale faut la
laisser environnementale faut pas la
traduire avec un coût de la tonne de CO2
et l'intégrer dans le résultat je pense
que ça c'est une aide qu'on peut faire
éventuellement dans des arbitrages
microéconomiques donnés
combien est-ce que mon investissement va
me coûter si demain matin la tonne de
carbone me coûte de temps mais c'est pas
la sonate la liste possible parce que on
peut aussi faire l'analyse en si j'ai
une restriction d'usage parce qu'on met
un quota sur les émissions
quelle est la rentabilité de mon
investissement c'est une autre question
qu'il faut se poser et celle-là elle a
rien à voir avec le prix de la tonne de
CO2
donc vous avez plein de manières de
faire rentrer le carbone dans des
analyses strictement économiques il n'y
a pas que via le prix du carbone et la
raison pour laquelle on parle énormément
de prix du carbone dans ce genre de
contexte c'est alors la raison est toute
bête ça va vous faire rire c'est parce
que c'est le seul truc que les économies
savent donner à manger à leur modèle
les économistes ne savent pas donner à
manger à leur modèle des modifications
de réglementation
ils savent juste les modèles
macroéconomiques qui sont basés sur des
élasticités volumes prix et donc on sait
leur faire dire quelque chose en faisant
des variations de prix point le reste on
sait pas donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle tous les économistes de la
planète sont favorables à la taxe
carbone c'est pas parce que c'est le
truc le plus intelligent sur terre ça ça
pertinence dans un certain nombre de
zones c'est juste le truc qui rentre
dans le modèle voilà
c'est exactement pour la même raison que
les stress tests climatiques des banques
sont basés sur des chocs de prix du
carbone c'est-à-dire le truc que vous
verrez jamais dans votre vie sauf si
Poutine nous coupe le gaz
et il n'intègre jamais des chocs
réglementaires par exemple les ZF
ça rentre pas dans un modèle de stress
bancaire c'est quand même susceptible de
modifier un tout petit peu les ventes
des constructeurs de voiture bon c'est
clair donc voilà donc c'est c'est voilà
c'est pour ça que on a donc moi je vous
mets en garde contre ça il faut que ça
reste séparé et il faut qu'à chaque fois
vous ayez un objectif donc on va passer
à une logique tableau de bord
vous cherchez pas à convertir en
équivalent essence le niveau de la jauge
d'huile sur une voiture vous dites pas
je calcule le volume total de fluides
qui a dans ma voiture en agrégeant
l'essence le liquide de freinage et
l'huile et le lave-glace et puis tant
que ça reste au dessus au dessus d'un
certain niveau et ben je considère que
tout va bien vous faites pas ça donc
vous regardez chaque chaque composant à
son utilité prise de manière séparée
voilà c'est exactement pareil il faut
que les comptabilités dites
extra-financières restent
extra-financière et donc ça renvoie ce
que je disais tout à l'heure il faut une
comptabilité carbone un peu un peu
détaillée si on veut passer à l'action
et il faut de l'analyse par scénario que
vous pourrez faire grâce à Iris merci
Jean-Manuel
enfin est-ce qu'il faut accompagner vos
clients vers la sobriété alors oui et
non une entreprise c'est un projet de
conquête toujours carbone 4 comme les
autres donc accompagner son client vers
moins de chiffre d'affaires c'est un
truc auquel on a du mal ce qu'on accepte
à la rigueur c'est d'accompagner son
client vers un cadre réglementaire plus
contraint que comme citoyen on aura
accepté
ça on accepte à la rigueur mais donc
c'est contre mauvaise fortune donc mais
accepter spontanément oui moi j'ai un
abonnement chez Orange qui me coûte 21
euros par mois
je vois mal orange me dire je vais vous
accompagner vers la sobriété votre
abonnement va passer à 12 euros et puis
je vous vendrai pas plus de smartphone
et pas plus de juste 12 euros voilà il y
a quelques raquettes figure dans
lesquelles ça peut exister alors je vais
vous donner un exemple à l'époque
Stéphane Richard n'avait pas pris cette
option publiquement mais Martin Bouygues
l'avait prise qui est le déploiement de
la 5G
le déploiement de la 5G m'avait expliqué
d'autres opérateurs coranges ça va nous
coûter un bras en investissements et on
augmentera pas leur pue donc on voit
juste par l'intérêt donc on est contre
alors il se trouve que moi ça m'arrange
bien parce que par ailleurs ça va
augmenter la dépense énergétique ça va
augmenter la dépense énergétique induite
parce qu'il va falloir faire tourner le
parc de smartphone ça va bouffer un peu
plus vite des ressources juste pour
regarder Netflix dans le métro alors que
je pense qu'on devrait les garder pour
être capable de continuer à avoir des
comptes en banque et de la comptabilité
d'entreprise un peu plus longtemps parce
que si un jour on a plus d'ordinateur il
y a plus de compte en banque non plus
hein
aujourd'hui on a quand même confié au
mine d'or de cuivre des temps etc je
vous refais pas la liste la possibilité
de payer nos impôts donc la fonction la
plus régalienne qui est un état qui est
de lever l'impôt aujourd'hui ça dépend
de mine
ça dépend de l'existence de mines et de
semi-conducteur
donc je pense que de gaspiller un peu
plus vite ce capital de départ juste
pour regarder Netflix dans le métro et
des sexes en 3D pas complètement
persuadé que ce soit totalement
indispensable on se limitera au sexe en
2D ça nous ira bien
on y arrivera encore et donc le
cette affaire de
d'accompagner les clients vers la
sobriété moi j'y crois pas je crois à
faire contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur
c'est à dire aider les clients à gérer
une sobriété que la puissance publique
leur demandera de gérer ou que les vos
clients auront envie de même de gérer
après vos clients seront pas
nécessairement les mêmes donc on
retourne à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure dans le monde vers lequel on va
vous avez intérêt mais ça renvoie au jus
de cerveau que vous avez intérêt à
investir donc moi je pense que dans la
direction marketing il faut multiplier
par 50 les effectifs qui s'occupent de
ce que je vais évoquer il faut regarder
tous les domaines dans lesquels en
vendant peu d'octets vous arrivez à
faire économiser quelque chose de
précieux à vos clients
de la chaleur de la recense métallique
des flux du transport qu'est-ce que je
sais et peut-être que votre avenir c'est
de devenir un Obs pur quelque part c'est
à dire un opérateur qui va proposer
essentiellement des services à haute
valeur ajoutée demandant beaucoup
d'intelligence et pas beaucoup d'octets
donc une infrastructure qui n'a pas
nécessairement besoin de faire transiter
des des giga bits dans tous les sens
d'image animée
et ça sera numériquement sobre pour vos
clients
mais
intéressant à plus d'un titre pour leurs
usages locaux et alors pour arriver à
faire ça il faut absolument alors si je
limite à la question du carbone il faut
absolument que vous ayez un scope 3
extrêmement détaillé parce que sans les
émissions des clients associées à
l'usage de vos services
en fait je vais vous lire autrement
carbone 4 fait aujourd'hui un peu plus
d'une centaine de personnes on est le
plus gros indépendant français dans la
comptabilité carbone Deloitte à eux tout
seul ils sont débiles donc on est 100
fois moins nombreux que juste la branche
française de l'un des big fort pour
compter des euros
voilà donc carbone 4 n'avions pas d'être
passé à 10000 personnes c'est juste pour
vous donner le rapport des forces en
présence entre l'argent et l'euro hein
mais effectivement en gros vous savez
notamment ce que la boîte remplisse ses
obligations de
de publication
on a un peu dépassé notre temps donc
je vous ai déjà répondu sur les
augmentations de salaire voilà qu'il
allait falloir méditer pour les baisses
alors
combien ça pèse de grammes de CO2
1 euro d'augmentation de salaire alors
attendez je vais faire un calcul d'ordre
de grandeur
les salaires en France c'est quoi c'est
60% du PIB en gros 50
on va dire 50 en ordre de grandeur donc
c'est 1200 milliards
de
d'euros et l'empreinte carbone de la
France et 700 millions de tonnes de CO2
donc ça veut dire 700 milliards de kilos
on est d'accord donc j'ai 1200 milliards
pour 700 milliards ça veut dire que je
suis pas loin pas très loin de un point
donc un euro d'augmentation de salaire
ça vaut quelques centaines de grammes de
d'émissions de CO2 en plus
voilà
il va falloir convaincre tout le monde
dans cette période de bataille pour le
pouvoir d'achat c'est pas gagné
après là je suis en train de vous parler
d'augmentation de salaire des flatter
puisque je raisonne PIB donc je résonne
corriger de l'inflation c'est vrai
alors après sur la question de l'action
des CSE en fait ce qui nous intéressait
le plus c'est de savoir si vous aviez
croisé des entreprises où il y avait des
CSE ou des organisations syndicales qui
avaient
lancer des actions particulièrement
pertinentes parce que à part agir sur
les activités social et culturelles pour
l'instant où demander certains comptes à
l'entreprise et justement la dernière
question c'est de savoir ce qu'il faut
lui demander qu'elle comment on peut
être légitime et efficace rapidement
alors
sans éviter de se former ça fait partie
des choses dont on a bien compris
qu'elles étaient importantes mais si on
repasse noyer dans les chiffres
qu'est-ce qu'on a demandé à la boîte
quel métrique et quelles informations
m'ont demandé pour bien jouer notre rôle
de
représentants des personnels dans les
CSE parce que c'est une question autour
de laquelle on a tourné pendant un
certain temps cette année
sans être complètement sûr de nous
dans les dans les leviers d'action pour
les élus CSE en lien avec avec notre
affaire ce qu'on a déjà ce que j'ai déjà
vu alors je sais pas à l'échelle mais ce
que je peux vous donner c'est de
l'organisation de conférence et donc de
transmission d'information
et il y a notamment alors je vous dis
pas ça pour vous faire de la pub mais il
se trouve que c'est un exemple que je
connais on a également au sein de
carbone 4 maintenant quelque chose qui
concerne l'empreinte carbone personnelle
qui s'appelle mycy auto et le modèle
économique de ce truc là c'est que c'est
gratuit pour les particuliers qui
s'inscrivent comme particuliers et c'est
payant pour les entreprises qui veulent
proposer ça à leur salarié
sachant que les gens qui viennent
s'inscrire à titre personnel on espère
qu'ils trouveront ça suffisamment bien
pour dire ensuite à leur entreprise
c'est quand même pas mal ce truc là
et c'est un atelier alors c'est
collectif et c'est la découverte
collectivement de sa propre empreinte
carbone personnelle donc c'est un
élément de sensibilisation et qui permet
d'embarquer les gens et on a déjà vu des
CSE proposées que ce genre de choses se
fasse de façon un peu large dans les
entreprises donc ça on a on a déjà vu
après dans les autres actions pour le
moment moi j'ai pas d'exemple évident en
tête mais c'est normal parce que cette
cette corde environnementale à votre arc
elle est quand même raisonnablement
récente et le rôle qu'on vous a confié
récemment d'aller chatouiller les
entreprises qui vous emploient sur cette
question là et relativement ce rôle est
récent
donc c'est normal que vous ayez pas
encore un milliard d'idées génial et il
va vous falloir comme l'entreprise à
laquelle vous appartenez monter en
compétences réfléchir engager des
groupes de travail regarder ce que font
les autres commencer à poser des calculs
et des règles de 3 enfin voilà il va
falloir faire des il va falloir faire ce
genre de choses
là où vous pouvez avoir un rôle direct
très rapidement c'est sur toutes les
activités que vous payez
donc pour tout ce qui est sorti vacances
etc vous pouvez très bien dire bah nous
on va s'appliquer la règle à nous aussi
c'est à dire qu'on va faire l'empreinte
carbone de tout ce qu'on de tout ce
qu'on finance et on vous fournira
l'information voir un jour on se donnera
une discipline propre en la matière
donc par exemple on perdra plus de
vacances avec des vols en avion
par exemple
eh oui
[Rires]
moi j'ai zéro problème avec ça mais bon
alors comment on a dépassé notre temps
on va simplement apprendre deux
questions dans la salle
une en bas et non je vous préviens que
je ne prends pas s'il y a deux questions
de question du même sexe
j'ai eu trois j'ai vu trois modes se
lever donc je vous dis tout de suite
dans la salle dans la salle moins 2 il y
a peut-être une dame qui veut poser une
question et on va commencer par la salle
du moins 2 puisque effectivement comme
ils sont
en dessous de nous et qui peuvent pas
laver les mains on les voit que par
écran interposé alors pour l'instant la
personne alors on va prendre un garçon
ici à condition qu'il y a une fille en
bas
on va commencer par le garçon alors
merci d'avoir pour toutes l'énergie
intellectuelle et humaine que vous
dépensez pour nous ouvrir les yeux
la question c'est
quelles entreprises ou organisation ou
entités vous pouvez nous citer comme
exemple qui vont dans la bonne
trajectoire de ces fameux 5%
5% strictosens j'ai pas d'exemple à vous
donner par contre dans les entreprises
ou organisation qui essayent de faire
des choses un peu sérieuses on va
trouver des gens qui en général que le
hasard a mis du bon côté de la barrière
et oui c'est souvent comme ça que les
choses se passent et dans les gens qui
comprennent qu'ils sont pas du bon côté
mais qui veulent faire pivoter de façon
absolument massive leur modèle
d'affaires on va trouver des gens pour
lesquels il y a soit des solutions
techniques qui peuvent être très
ambitieuses
soit la possibilité de réorienter
complètement le modèle d'affaires et là
on va plutôt trouver des ETI que de
trouver des grands groupes parce que les
grands groupes c'est plus compliqué
enfin exactement on va trouver des
entreprises qui sont pas totalement
rentières en position dominante dans
leur marché donc les entreprises qui
sont rentières en position dominante
dans leur marché ont énormément de mal à
pivoter de manière de manière forte
alors dans les quelques dans les
quelques choses que je peux vous citer
qui sont un peu rigolotes je vais vous
en citer deux ou trois
c'est pas la peine aux hommes de lever
la main je ne prendrai pas de question
d'homme derrière cette cette
vous avez le je vais vous citer deux
exemples marrants un c'est le comité
champagne
les producteurs de champagne font partie
des gens qui ont baissé pas de 5 % par
an mais qui ont baissé en valeur absolue
leurs émissions enfin les émissions de
leur bilan carbone ces dernières années
alors même que la production augmentait
et ils ont fait les choses alors ils
m'ont dit un jour en rigolant la
Champagne c'est le seul pays communiste
qui a réussi parce que on fait tous le
même produit on le fait tous de la même
manière voilà on le voit pas tous au
même prix et on est très riche donc ça
soit le pays communiste qui a réussi
et mais le fait est que comme ils font
tous le même produit du coup c'est c'est
facile de faire de façon collaborative
énormément de groupes de réflexion pour
réfléchir à comment ils peuvent allerger
la bouteille comment ils peuvent parce
que la bouteille c'est un des gros
composants du bilan carbone comment ils
peuvent utiliser moins de fioul pour la
protection contre le gel comment etc ils
peuvent faire des trucs de manière
collaborative et l'autre exemple que je
vais vous citer alors celui là il est
pas mis en oeuvre il pourrait l'être
c'est le la transformation des hauts
fourneaux d'Arcelor à Dunkerque
qui pourrait passer de la réduction du
minerai de fer par le coq ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui donc on prend du
charbon pour enlever l'oxygène du
minerai de fer et avoir de la fonte à la
réduction directe à l'hydrogène
d'hydrogène venant des réacteurs
nucléaires d'à côté il faut quand même
un petit réacteur nucléaire par au
fourneau qu'on remplace
et là et on pourrait effectivement
diviser les émissions de CO2 par 5 ou 10
assez facilement enfin c'est facilement
il faut faire un gros investissement
mais je veux dire c'est techniquement
possible voilà deux exemples que je peux
vous citer où il y a des gens qui ont
identifié des marges de manœuvre pas
nécessairement mis en oeuvre certains
oui d'autres non quand vous êtes dans un
domaine dans lequel vous êtes encore une
fois en position dominante sur votre
marché c'est très très difficile
d'accepter de tout mettre cul par dessus
tête au risque de diviser votre chiffre
d'affaires par deux j'ai là j'ai pas
d'exemple à vous proposer dans les dans
les très grands groupes encore une fois
dans des plus petites entreprises là il
y a des gens qui peuvent se gratter la
tête de manière très significative et
enclencher orientation qui peuvent être
assez significatives
oui bonjour
c'est une fille aux étages inférieurs
[Rires]
nous avions une question à vous poser
vous n'avez pas parlé donc des énergies
des carbonées
hydroélectriques fusion nucléaire quel
est votre point de vue là-dessus
d'accord alors vous savez j'ai été bon
élève on m'a pas posé de questions sur
le sujet donc moi je répondais aux
questions qu'on m'a posé comme à l'école
les énergies décarbonées qu'on appelle
aussi
renouvelable et nucléaire parce qu'en
gros vous avez les deux elle regroupe
l'ensemble de
la biomasse dès lors qu'elle est
exploitée de manière renouvelable ou
tous ces dérivés
à gros carburant biogaz etc et puis les
modes de production électrique sans ou
avec peu de carbone et là dedans vous
avez par ordre d'importance décroissante
dans le monde l'hydroélectricité le
nucléaire l'éolien avant je dois avoir
la géothermie puis solaire ça doit être
dans cet ordre là que c'est au niveau
mondial
alors un petit rappel historique si
j'accepte l'énergie du CLR toutes ces
énergies sont dites renouvelables il se
trouve que les énergies renouvelables
composaient 100% de l'approvisionnement
électrique de l'approvisionnement
énergétique pardon mondial il y a deux
siècles et demi donc en fait les
énergies renouvelables c'est les
énergies dont nous sommes sortis pour
passer aux énergies fossiles et beaucoup
plus marginalement nucléaire et si on a
fait ça c'est qu'il y a des raisons
physiques et donc la possibilité de
revenir en masse à ces énergies
renouvelables pour remplacer les
énergies fossiles en ayant toujours la
5G et 40 mètres carrés chauffés par
personne personnellement j'y crois pas
c'est à dire que ça sera pas à l'échelle
on y arrivera pas
la question est donc les énergies
renouvelables elles sont essentiellement
donc on peut y faire appel c'est une
bonne idée d'y faire appel c'est pas
nécessairement sans inconvénient et je
vais en donner quelques-uns rapidement
en ce qui concerne les agrocarburants
l'inconvénient c'est que vous avez une
concurrence d'usage avec les surfaces
qui sont dédiées à l'agriculture à la
préservation de la biodiversité ou à des
ressources non alimentaires autre par
exemple des fibres du bois etc
et toujours pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur aux États-Unis vous avez 40 %
du maïs qui finit comme éthanol dans les
réservoirs de SUV on pourrait tout aussi
bien diminuer un peu la masse des
voitures des Américains ça les tuerait
pas et ça éviterait de mobiliser ces
surfaces pour faire pousser du maïs
donc il y a un problème sur la biomasse
qui est la concurrence d'usage des sols
et en fait à l'échelle mondiale on
déforeste encore aujourd'hui ce qui veut
dire que si on veut accroître la
biomasse pour des usages énergétiques on
va déforester encore plus c'est ça qui
va se passer en pratique
de carbone la deuxième
la deuxième limite des énergies
renouvelables c'est qu'elles sont
souvent diffuses donc par exemple le
vent et le soleil il y en a beaucoup en
totale sur terre mais il y en a peu par
unité de surface ou par unité de temps
et donc il faut des grandes grandes
dispositifs de collecte pour en avoir
des quantités importantes et c'est ça
qui a limité le fait qu'on soit capable
de passer à une civilisation
industrielle sur la base de ces énergies
diffuses et par ailleurs il y a un
deuxième problème c'est que quand vous
avez des modes de production qui ne
fournissent que de l'électricité
l'électricité de ce stock pas en tant
que tel
et donc ça limite également très
fortement le déploiement les
combustibles fossiles à contrario sont
très dense par unité de volume ou parité
de poids donc ce transporte très
facilement peuvent s'utiliser
indépendamment des conditions
climatiques locales des conditions
géographiques locales partout dans le
monde et donc c'est ça qui a favorisé
leur leur expansion donc les énergies
des carbonées renouvelables vont buter
sur des limites physiques à leur
déploiement et juste pour vous donner un
exemple l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie a publié récemment un
graphique dans lequel il montre que les
mines de cuivre actuellement en
exploitation ou en développement
passe ou passeront par leur pic de
production maintenant là maintenant dans
les deux années qui viennent
ce qui veut dire que tous ces scénario
de déploiement quel qu'il soit qui
compte sur une augmentation de l'appel à
du cuivre
risque de se heurté un problème de
disponibilité de la ressource primaire
et si on commence à prospecter pour
trouver de nouvelles mines qu'on va
éventuellement exploiter vous êtes parti
pour 15 ans à minimum
pardon
ah vous avez une mine dans le réseau de
cuivre vous pouvez aussi couper le
réseau de cuivre existant mais là ça
posera d'autres problèmes
vous avez donc voilà donc on risque de
buter sur des limites en donc la limite
des énergies renouvelables enfin des
énergies des carbonées renouvelables va
être pour l'essentiel des limites
physiques pour mettre de nouveaux
barrages il faut des montagnes si on les
a pas voilà en Belgique on va avoir du
mal à remplacer le nucléaire par des
barrages pour etc donc vous avez un
certain nombre de limite physique le
nucléaire lui il a peu de limite
physique par contre il a beaucoup de
limites en compétences alors le
nucléaire a peu de limite physique parce
que l'énergie nucléaire elle est par
construction un million de fois plus
dense que l'énergie chimique pour ceux
d'entre vous à qui ça va rappeler des
souvenirs l'énergie chimique c'est à
dire la combustion c'est un
réarrangement des couches électroniques
d'un atome ces quelques électrons volts
paratum
la fission nucléaire c'est un
réarrangement des nucléons du noyau
c'est 200 millions d'électrons volts par
fission alors le noyau d'uranium est
beaucoup plus lourd que le noyau de
carbone ou le noyau de l'hydrogène mais
si je fais la combinaison des deux le
résultat des courses c'est que quand
vous fissionnez un gramme d'uranium ça
libère autant d'énergie quand vous
brûlez une tonne de pétrole
donc l'énergie nucléaire est extrêmement
concentrée et extrêmement dense et donc
avec de faibles quantités de matériaux
et de métal l'uranium étant un métal
vous arrivez à avoir de très grandes
quantités d'énergie et avec les
technologies appropriées on est capable
enfin on serait plus exactement capable
d'avoir de grandes quantités d'énergie
sur terre des carbonées pour très
longtemps pas avec ce qu'on utilise
actuellement pas avec l'uranium 235 mais
par contre vous avez une barrière de
compétence parce que c'est très long
c'est compliqué de faire une centrale
nucléaire c'est long et compliqué d'en
faire beaucoup c'est long et compliqué
de débattre avec la population pour lui
faire dire oui oui on a envie d'en avoir
beaucoup etc donc c'est tout ça est
compliqué et du coup la limite au
nucléaires c'est sa vitesse de
déploiement
beaucoup plus que les matériaux que ça
va consommer de manière intrinsèque
on pourrait également parler pendant des
heures de la question des accidents des
déchets etc quand vous regardez ça au
fond en fait vous vous rendez compte que
c'est pas une nuisance significative
face aux accidents de la route ou au
tabac
donc c'est fin si vous avez des enfants
moi je vous conseille de faire beaucoup
plus gaffe quand il traverse la rue que
quand il passe à proximité d'une
centrale nucléaire donc la
enfin j'étais vous donc la question du
nucléaire est une question je le dis ou
le frein principal c'est la vitesse de
déploiement et le fait que entre le
moment où on décide d'avoir un plan et
le moment où le plan est fini les filles
exécuté il se passe énormément de temps
c'est ça le c'est ça ça limite si on
fait le total de toutes ces énergies des
carbonées aujourd'hui dans le monde on
est à si j'accepte la biomasse à 10%
j'ai fait un petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur pour que on conserve le la
croissance économique et la nôtre
aujourd'hui en passant le fossile au
décarboné il faudrait que le rythme
d'augmentation du décarbonate tous les
ans se baladent entre cette et 10% par
an tous les décarbonés confondus
aujourd'hui on en est très très loin et
surtout on est très très loin de pouvoir
poursuivre ce rythme pendant des
décennies
donc la le recours aux énergies des
carbonées c'est il faut toujours le
prendre là où on peut le prendre mais ça
ne fera pas la totalité du chemin et
donc on va devoir où nous devons subir à
cause de ce que j'ai dit en introduction
tout à l'heure de toute façon
si je le dis de manière un peu taquine
une cure d'amaigrissement si je le dis
de manière plus positive une sobriété
souhaitée
dans nos usages matériels pris de
manière globale
ça va être le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup
merci à vous